This story is sponsored by MarketerHire.
In January, something strange happened in
North Korea.
The entire nation’s internet kept blacking
out.
The notoriously restrictive country runs a
few dozen websites from the booking site for
its national airline to a page that serves
as the official portal for Kim Jong-un's government.
The timing of the outages was peculiar.
They coincided with a bunch of North Korean
missile tests…prompting suspicions that
the US Defense Department might have been
behind it.
After all, a single independent hacker couldn’t
have pulled off such an audacious attack.
Could they?
Well, Wired magazine interviewed an American
hacker who does claim to be behind the blackouts.
According to the news outlet, they’ve seen
screen recordings to back up his claims.
He’s known only as “P4x” due to concerns
for his safety.
He says he carried out his attacks for revenge.
In January 2021, North Korean hackers attacked
him and other security researchers who used
Windows PCs and Google Chrome.
Google says the North Korean hackers set up
Twitter accounts pretending to be cybersecurity
bloggers and shared links with their victims
to a blog with malware that contained a backdoor
to try to access the victims’ device remotely
without their knowledge.
Google never said how successful the hackers
were.
P4x was shocked that North Korea tried to
target him though in his case, they didn’t
succeed.
Nonetheless, it left him “deeply unnerved”
by the attack and also what he felt was a
lack of response from the U.S. government.
So, he slowly cooked up a plan to get even,
waiting a year to launch an attack of his
own.
He says he took North Korea offline while
in his pajamas watching the film Aliens and
munching on spicy corn snacks!
North Korea News, an information source that
provides news about the country, reported
a Distributed Denial of Service (DDoS) attack
on January 14 followed by another on January
26.
P4x says he targeted “vulnerabilities”
in North Korean systems.
He didn’t describe what those are because
he doesn’t want Pyongyang to defend against
them in the future.
He did give an example of a bug that mishandles
certain HTTP headers that allowed him to flood
the servers, overwhelming them and knocking
them offline.
Almost every North Korean website went down.
So did email and all internet-based services.
Though it didn’t affect access to sites
hosted outside that country.
But what did the hack achieve?
After all, virtually no citizens in the hermit
kingdom can access the internet.
Only a few thousand have special permission
to go online in a country of nearly 26 million.
So as hard as it is for foreigners to understand
what’s happening inside North Korea, it’s
even harder for North Koreans to understand
anything about the outside world.
P4x admits his own hacking was symbolic.
Akin to tearing down government banners or
defacing buildings.
He told Wired he did it to send a message
to North Korea that he wouldn’t tolerate
their hacking: “If they don’t see we have
teeth, it’s just going to keep coming.”
North Korea’s cyber warfare has caught the
West off guard.
Ironically, a country that’s closed itself
off from the rest of the world has produced
some of the world’s most efficient hackers.
7,000 North Koreans are estimated to be employed
in their country’s cyber program.
They often operate abroad, in countries like
China where there’s better access to information
than in their isolated homeland.
These three men wanted by the FBI are suspected
of belonging to a unit of North Korean hackers
dubbed the Lazarus Group - a reference to
the biblical figure raised from the dead by
Jesus.
The Lazarus Group is believed to be behind
some of the costliest cyberattacks in history.
Like the infamous Sony leak - where hackers
released five Sony Pictures films and a host
of confidential data in 2014.
They threatened more action if Sony dared
to release the film “The Interview”, a
comedy featuring Seth Rogan and James Franco
about two Americans who assassinate Kim Jong
Un.
In 2016, the Lazarus Group nearly stole $1
billion from Bangladesh’s national bank.
The ONLY reason they didn’t succeed is because
of a fluke.
When they tried to transfer the money to a
bank located on “Jupiter Street” - the
word “Jupiter” triggered alarms because
it’s the name of a sanctioned Iranian shipping
vessel.
Lazarus Group has crippled the computer systems
of Boeing, the UK’s National Health Service,
and Germany’s federal railway - demanding
payment in Bitcoin to unfreeze their systems.
North Korean hackers seem to love crypto.
They stole nearly $400 million in cryptocurrencies
in 2021, according to the data platform Chainalysis.
The United Nations believes much of that money
is used to fund North Korea’s weapons program,
including developing nuclear missiles.
So how does a country where most people can’t
even access a computer produce elite cyber-criminals?
The North Korean hackers are cultivated in
the same way Olympians in China are trained
and go on to dominate the Games.
They’re recruited when they’re young.
Promising students who excel at math are placed
in specialized schools and trained in advanced
coding, with further training at specialized
universities.
And they show off their coding prowess at
international coding competitions.
The New Yorker put it this way:
The coding and the analytical skills on display
at such events were like the Force in the
“Star Wars” movies: it could be used for
the light side, or for the dark.
As for P4X, temporarily shutting down North
Korea’s internet was simply the appetizer
before the main course.
He says he intends to go further by trying
to hack into North Korea’s systems to steal
information and share it with experts.
According to Wired, he’s hoping to recruit
more people to his cause and apparently launched
a site on the dark web called “FUNK Project”.
Can you take a stab at what that might stand
for?
“FU North Korea”.
Thanks to you, Newsthink has hit 375,000 subscribers
on YouTube in a year and a half.
If you’re thinking of growing your audience
no matter what business you’re in, my sponsor
MarketerHire can help you hire the best marketing
talent.
Whether you’d like help with promoting your
product, advice on how to build a bigger,
better email list, or how to get more return
on your ad spending, you’ll find the very
best freelancers on MarketerHire.
The benefit of hiring a freelancer over an
employee is that you only pay for the time
and skills you need.
Hiring the right person can be hard as you
may not know whether they’re really as good
as they say they are.
Well, MarketerHire vets the experts for you.
They only work with the cream of the crop.
Their acceptance rate is 4%, which is less
than Harvard!
You can try out MarketerHire today using my
custom link in the description and pinned
comment: marketerhire.com/newsthink and they’ll
match you up in 48 hours with the perfect
person to help grow your business.
Thanks for watching.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.